hello welcome back to GameSpot's
coverage of e3 2016 I'm Daniel wire
hello welcome it's a final two hours
here on the gamespot stage we're talking
to a bunch of people here serene hello
allows you to have you here thank you
with Greg rice from the Double Fine
entertainment I and his latest intern
named Timothy little little Timmy me
Schafer Timmy Schafer us that's him like
you so much for joining us thank you for
having us a pleasure as always let's
talk about head Lander and that's the
game of it may might be flying under the
radar for some people at Double Fine
obviously you've got a lot of big
projects going on at the moment it's
like a Nazi I joined yesterday with the
rhombus rune tell us about head'll under
how long you guys been working on this
one this is a game by lee petty who is
the art director and brutal legend and
also made stacking if you play that yes
some adventure game where you're jumping
in Russian nesting dolls and this time
it's very different it's a retro science
fiction world inspired a lot by logans
run or barbarella and as you can see
it's a little different in the mechanics
in that you are the last piece of
organic matter in the galaxy just ahead
you're just a head floating around in a
flying space helmet and you can land on
the next socket of any exam robots that
are handy and take them over and walk
them around and those robot bodies give
you different weapons and abilities and
kind of sizes and so that's a unique
mechanic this game as right at lighting
looks super swish is this Unreal Engine
you guys using it up this is this is the
brutal legend engine oh it is oh really
yeah works well with the shirt then
thank you yeah that's me perfect so who
is the name of your head here and what
is he or she or can you be different
heads or how does it work you can choose
one of three different heads yeah this
this is the new hazard you picked
anything I did pick up ahead does he
have a name where she just names that
you don't know much about him he kind of
wake up you're just a head to the body
nobody really know now you're on the
ladies buddy yes exactly so there's a
lot of mystery there that's yet to be
unveiled well yeah this is the new head
he's kind of like a 60 year old
african-american male
where'd you sure he's really good dancer
oh nice he may not have been a good
dancer before but being on that robots
body giving the ability to it's
wonderful and does the head you choose
make a difference on anything in the
game itself or is it like aesthetic
thing the head I think I believe is the
same but it's the bodies that you choose
to really make the difference what's the
sort of makeup of had the game the level
string together I was kind of looking up
before and this seems like a
Metroidvania yes necessary I'm the main
thing we're talking about for the first
time here at e3 is it showing off a
little bit more of the Metroid stuff so
if you if you saw I just pulled the map
up a little bit earlier right so
something haven't showed too much so
this is kind of areas that we've
unlocked so far but this is a new
character called mapi have we haven't
shown his voice actually Richard Horvitz
voice of Raz it kind of like a little
mall directory very helpful right yeah
super helpful but you can you can select
the head off of him well and land in his
body go on my feet they control the mapi
mm-hmm I know you've always dreamed to
do exactly oh and you see the map yeah
so he shows my areas that you haven't
been to yet some secrets around the area
as well you may not know this but the
children's channel in the UK when I was
growing up watching on the UK and
Ireland they're like corporate like
person was a massive map of the British
Isles called mafi really yes that was
obviously the inspiration for this right
yeah yeah um even though Lee did not
grow up in the UK no way but um but you
see the head has a lot of power is it so
it can suck and like barriers out of its
way and it can dock with stations like
this to get power-ups or energy or and
yes there's another new thing actually
so this is XP we haven't showed too much
of that but that blue bar at the bottom
is XP and that's what these orbs have
been that I've been pulling up and yeah
the the vacuum drive is something that
we unlocked in the demo section right
before this but there's actually a bunch
of other upgrades throughout the game
and a lot of them are things like this
melee power looks like we have just
enough to upgrade things like this that
is player choice said you can kind of
decide how you want to play this unlock
new branches and make it even stronger
and then there's also these main
branches which are things will find
throughout the level that are kind of
tied more to the the gating system the
Metroidvania nature of things do you
expect somebody's completed the game to
have unlocked all of this sort of stuff
or is that if you're a completionist you
yeah you can unlock everything but
there's a lot of hidden areas
and things that you cannot have to reach
a verse and find certain power-ups to
come back to so if you haven't done much
of that you'll you'll have to choose a
little bit more wisely and if you're
replaying the game can you like keep
your experience for the stuff you've
unlocks and like progress further it's a
completed there are some plans for like
new game+ type stuff that we're trying
to figure out right now or not not quite
sure exactly but yeah I mean a lot of it
is I think when you were playing the
game there's a lot more ability to kind
of cheat and pick and choose differently
in figure play style in different ways
the arts on this is super fun it's like
another world mixed with what was the
name the this forget there was like that
PlayStation 4 when we were making
doubles of yourself swapper the swallow
yeah yeah let's pop her it had some of
that puzzle e element to it but I really
if you lead loves a logan's run and he
one of the first things he said when you
start the games i want to make lasers
cool again because i think blazers got a
lot less especially 70 styles lasers
where there's a rainbow spectrum and as
a lot of chrome kind of before Star Wars
came in everything all pretty alright
there's a lot of beautiful stuff like
this and I think it shows like a lot of
love for that great carpus shag yeah i'm
gonna get my shed yeah you played any
games with shag at e3 it's been a while
I mean there's not one o'clock work arms
looking thing what does it call again we
happy few yeah yeah I guess maybe
they've got some shag not jag like this
no your particular brand of shock is
just beautiful no psychedelic there's
Alex up yeah so speaking of lasers we
just got that kind of the first combat
area of the game so this is uh this is a
shepherd that we just come across and
use he is standing with more confidently
yes mm-hmm like a shepherd yes so he's a
red shepherd with a single shot by the
game actually has a ton of different
kind of enemies throughout the game a
lot of different types of variations on
the weapons to where they could be
spread shots or double shots things like
that but there's also kind of a
color-coded system to wear at the bottom
right you'll see we just got into a red
body so now we have read access
clearance so we're on the doors that we
passed earlier on we could come back to
and and and find some secrets there and
that that's tied to this color spectrum
so there's orange bodies although we
have two purple the purple have the
highest clearance they can get in any
room
where the red just can get into the red
doors soccer blind modes gonna be a real
son of a [ __ ] we've got things in place
for that okay yeah you can kind of
running gun and just shoot a bodies and
they'll explode if you damage them too
much like that there's also this cover
system I'm about the right now pop out
of that there's a cover system in place
to to kind of to line up shots a little
bit more so if you have a body that's
kind of weekend and about to blow a lot
of times you'll need to to make sure
that you pick off the head of a
character my skills body instead of
hitting us at destroying the bank can
also use your body as a weapon that that
had that bodies but if it's about to
blow you can send it charging to someone
else pop off of it let it blow up your
enemy for you there's a lot of variety
to the to the combat scenarios and it is
buried every time there's different
types of bodies that will spawn in a
different room so you never really know
exactly what you're gonna get into a lot
of people in the chat saying it looks
very charming some references to no one
lives forever as well with some of the I
guess the vibrant 70s sort of color here
if you have any questions for Gregor Tim
by all means put them in the child and
watching the game spot shot and of
course the twit shot as well now I'll be
sure to send those over at the Disco
matter found easier for tonight so you
guys still do that we do 74 900 in a
while because I waiting for this game to
get right but um we it was interesting
because we had this Lee had this idea
and we actually put it in one of our
major for tonight's that where the
internet got to pick okay and internet
didn't pick this one and I was like okay
the internet that's what I'm learning
and it's not always right you know that
kind of wrong sometimes because this is
obviously the greatest the greatest game
what's daddy pig wait what did they pick
I mean that was the year I think they
picked why don't want pick up a bunch of
good games they're all good they're all
good but uh I really ever since a lead
pitched it and I saw the kind of the
puzzle mechanics possible with this like
getting over a gorge by jumping your
head over instead of you know leaping
into you know there's a lot of ended now
you can be a dog it's perfect and just
seeing the possibility this I knew we
wanted to make it so we just kind of
fought for it and and until now it's a
reality we're working with adult swim on
it the part of it yeah that partnership
come about I think we were just sharing
this game I think they were looking for
games like this they didn't look like
any other game that looked really
unusual right you know their sensibility
is very they like to push creative
boundaries enough and that's
really great in the publisher because a
lot of times the publisher would be like
let's just 82 something that people know
and I think it'll swim on to like they
actually just told Lee just go for it
which is exciting to hear from a partner
and that it's coming out on pc mac and
ps4 right no xbox one version it's
launching up you guys for first so okay
all right yeah get around to it
potentially down the road sir so I go on
through I was going to ask when you pop
off a body and it stays there does it
say that forever like for the rest of
the level or she's kind of disappear
after a while you know they'll stick
around there and actually if you find
later on you might come back to the same
room and that that that I've got a lot
of yeah they'll fill another body I'll
come out with the same name so they'll
be it like having the two or something
instead of Evan one right so this is
actually a main upgrade station we just
found so like the vacuum driver we have
before we just kind of found one of
these new main upgrade paths which is
the bounce shield I just say that menu
transition is brilliant yeah do it again
do it again rude yeah that's gras I got
a hotline Miami it takes a while for us
to tune in on the signal of the matter
rockin so now there's a whole nother
chain off of this but we just have this
bounce field which if you notice before
I passed a couple of these continuous
laser beams which you can get by but now
I have this shield I can use the right
stick to kind of swivel around to be
able to traverse from these areas but
it's also using combat situations to be
able to bounce shots back out it back
enemies but he just dr. the laser
control turn it off to Louisville a lot
of people saying is sort of impressed by
high polish this look that you guys
pretty far along on this one when does
it come in with movie all right yes it's
coming out late July so we've been
working for a while and it's very very
very close and greg i was talking before
we went live I've actually not played a
game at e3 2016 don't care for games
I've not I love video games it's an
awkward place they were better than
leaving don't like game play video game
I would love to play right home okay I
just got you into a new section is gonna
use your bounce shield so you're bound
seals on the right stick okay and you're
gonna be able to actually can you can
deflect these back of them and blow them
up don't do that i was looking at that
screen okay later right yeah here we go
but it's also a section that you just
wouldn't have been able to get through
without this and in the map
really open to where you could have
gotten here before you got the bounce
shield we have we just kind of got into
a main mission goodbye night wasn't he's
gonna bunt the head of the head Yeah
right trigger sucks the head there you
go yes bluff bumper will capitate your
first fell one will uh doc there you go
great and I you can you throw the enemy
heads at them often come on the left
trigger will cover or you can also blood
go pull aside I put the wrong box you
got i press the wrong button you got it
lots of ways to approach your situation
ok some was it oh damn it it's very
forgiving so if you die you're pretty
much your may be in the same room it for
one room next to it or something so we
it's not super low and that transit and
then the cover is left left ringer if
you want to cover their alright i'll
hold it got in then you can right
trigger to fire died oh I like that you
can line up your shot yeah the love
stickel aim your shot if you want to
like try it off for that yeah you're go
for the head shot yeah I'm like cover yo
Oh terminal yeah Oh what does that do oh
yeah mission right now which is to find
the five satellite dishes and you just
found the first of that so you can dock
into there and tune this out I get that
yeah yes you don't into that me the blue
like to control that outta like this
yeah emailing the character yeah yeah
and then use the left stick movie left
and you'll see it kind of tune in this
is that you you're trying to get back in
touch with this I radio voice that's
kind of talking to you in your head
throughout the entire game right that
sounds very familiar yes like it's to
the left there's a couple radio stations
here so people here in your home might
hear some fun music and little
announcements yes but I've got the ear
piece here so I can hear it needn't
there you go i think you got it boom
good stuff that's one of five you look
at your map there's five others
throughout the room say look at your map
like I know what the price but I did you
did the matter is new it's amazing just
do this for the next I'm gonna barf oh
just close everyone who sorry for the
scene if you pull up that pole with me
again look at the upgrade system now use
the d-pad to move around that but
there's some interesting stuff if you go
up to the bounce shield you'll see now I
think you could unlock body regeneration
that one's long as a double shield
there's one to the bottom right that's a
headbutt take over so you can head but
an enemy and take over his body
immediately without having to launch
nice
crazy stuff ability to shoot in a
direction and launch your head and
create a turret that's pointing at the
direction that vacuum force I think that
just makes your vacuum a little bit
stronger why can I get that for my
vacuum at home like yeah there yeah yeah
thank you so much for coming in and then
yeah okay like video game I played a
video game you know people say let me
ask you what's the best game you play
today three so far ahead london yeah has
to be a subscribe nobody Chris that was
my vesca what was the best candy you ate
at e3 I haven't eaten any candy yet but
depends how much this cost he's for the
free oh the free you can have them all
things we can share them we have it
right don't me exactly what my cut is of
plugging there is the candy that's yours
fifty percent of all I got thanks so
much come again everybody else he doing
are these for you done so now is that it
where we last showing lots of games we
had psychonauts VR on here yesterday but
we're also showing David O'Reilly
everything and dog from coop and it's
it's been good speaker 3 and if folks
wanna pick up head Lander when is it
available end of july good stuff tick
tock or and pc all this stuff alright so
thank you so much come in thanks for
harry said you're watching the game spot
stage brought to you by airheads bites